on est au jour 5 de la grève des
employés du cnc pour le moment le
ministre de l'énergie et des ressources
naturelles jonathan julien se veut
rassurant à très court terme en tout cas
il ya quand même beaucoup d'agriculteurs
qui craignent une pénurie de propane on
les a vus d'ailleurs un coup d'éclat
hier au centre-ville de montréal
notamment les producteurs de grains
j'en parle avec sylvain odette
professeur à hec membre associé à la
chaire de gestion du secteur de
l'énergie se dit bonjour bonjour qu'est
ce qui vous préoccupe le plus en ce
moment avec cette grève et cette pénurie
possible de propane
ben c'est qu'est ce qui va se passer au
delà du 5 jours semble qu'on a à peu
près de 10 à 12 millions de lettres
disponible pour le moment mais qu'est ce
qui va arriver après ce qu'ils vont
trouver une solution pour essayer de
faire venir un peu plus
d'approvisionnement ici au québec
cette crise-là a mis au jour le fait
qu'elle peut on était dépendante pour
atteindre dans les fermes mais chez les
agriculteurs
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne savait pas
nécessairement faut regarder ce problème
là sur 12 en langue l'approvisionnement
en cette ressource l'ordre ils sont
continuer à utiliser le propane c'est
quoi les sources d'approvisionnement il
ya deux choses approvisionnements le
papa c'est un produit dérivé
l'extraction de gaz naturel dans l'ouest
principalement et puis il est transporté
par pipeline de l'ouest à sarnia et l'a2
sarnia au québec c'est souvent par terre
donc la première chose c'est d'essayer
de voir est ce qu'il y avait moyen de
faire venir du propane plus
régulièrement parce qu'il ya une
capacité repose âge quand même limitée
ici avec chaque producteur aussi propre
réseau d'entreposage ou l'autre
alternative son niveau de la demande est
ce que les producteurs de grains ou même
les gens qui utilisent papale au niveau
pour l'urgence ou des régions éloignées
comme iso plutôt qu'on a entendu hier il
ya déjà commencé à diffuser dans le
transport est ce qu'il ya des
alternatives au niveau de la demande de
même après on veut utiliser de propane
parce qu'on leur trouve qu'on est bon
c'est ça ce qu'elles sont inchangés ce
qu'on pourrait se tourner vers
technologies plus vertes aller vers
l'électricité par exemple plutôt que
d'utiliser le problème bon c'est sûr que
lorsqu'on veut créer de la chaleur fait
relâche à la le propane est quand même
un très bon conduite mais si on veut en
garder d'autres alternatives
la première alternative ça serait de
regarder s'il ya pas moyen d'étendre le
réseau de gaz naturel d énergie mais bon
ça aussi ça a des limites ça coûte cher
la deuxième alternative ça serait de
faire du gaz naturel liquéfié c'est
aussi ça coûte cher donc pourrait
transporter du gaz naturel la troisième
alternative celle que est mentionné ça
serait d'utiliser d'électricité pour
peut-être une fusée d'une veille
technologique sera base électricité
ainsi qu'au cabinet grosse problématique
à ce niveau là au delà du fait que ça
pourrait être un peu plus cher au niveau
que l'été n'est pas mature c'est d'avoir
accès à de l'électricité distribuée
d'homère triphasé on n'est pas mono
phase et dans les régions rurales
seulement 40 % au québec du réseau
distribution qui est alimenté à fait
possible d'alimenter en triphasé ayons
des producteurs agricoles ça fait des
années qu'elle revendique le besoin
d'avoir si on veut électrifier le
secteur agricole radar des réseaux de
gaz métro d'énergie je m'excuse il faut
avoir plus d'électricité triphasé donc
ça serait une des solutions aussi au
delà des autres considérations que le
criphase et ça veut dire quoi ça change
quoi exactement
ça permet d'aller chercher plus de
puissance au niveau de l' usage de
l'énergie
évidemment c'est chez du grain passé de
30 % d'humidité à 15 % d'humidité
ça prend une source d'énergie qui est
capable donné beaucoup de puissance et
le propane jusqu'à nouvel ordre et quand
même une source d'énergie la moins
polluante disponibles sont comparé à
d'autres sources et qui est beaucoup de
puissance donc faut trouver des
alternatives comme le tri pause mais
vous en tant qu'expert quand vous
regardez que quelques jours de grève au
cn
ça peut créer des problèmes aussi
importants pour les producteurs de
grains notamment est ce que vous vous
dites on est trop à la merci du propane
et il faut vraiment changer les choses
je veux ramener un peu soi qu'on va
chercher d'autres façons d'aller
s'approvisionner en propane
où on trouve des alternatives mais cette
année c'est quand même exceptionnel un
nouveau des agriculteurs on a eu un
hiver un ebook ou neige qui tombe ça
fait que les lille le mais c'est encore
dans les changes
je me promenais sur bar du soulier je
voyais des gens qui étaient embourbés
dans la neige avec la messe
en plus cette année il a encore plus
humide il est même pas encore récolté
donc il ya une demande encore plus
importante pour ces agriculteurs donc il
comme une tempête parfaite pour eux sans
vouloir faire de mauvais jeu de mots qui
ne sont rien en plus sur la grève du cn
non c'est un peu passé pour jason kenny
aussi qui veut plus loin il met
notamment des alternatives ce serait
justement de ses devoirs à ce que y
aurait moyen de réutiliser les les
pipelines qui sont tout de suite le gaz
naturel présentement et simplement dire
bon de voir dédier vous savez des
pipelines en fait pour un seul pipeline
c'est plusieurs pipelines soit qui sont
collés à côté de l'autre dédié 1 pour
transporter du gaz propane plus proche
de la frontière du québec où est d'aller
chercher à servir il demeure ça voudrait
dire réouvrir le dossier d'énergie
est-ce peut-être et mais bon les
pipelines sont déjà leur jusqu'à la
frontière du québec s'est pas construit
de nouveaux pipelines sera dépassé sa
d'un territoire québécois issus
habilités sociales
jodie pipeline qui existent déjà que
transporte déjà de leur naturel donc est
ce que ce serait possible de regarder ça
dans le futur ça sonne alternative sinon
mais je vous dis c'est passé par
l'électricité mais là il ya des enjeux
aussi une foule de la description va
vraiment ce que ça donne sur le terrain
comme conséquence probable j'espère que
ça se règle en plus aux négociations
cette semaine chez le cn merci beaucoup
c'est leur dette
merci bien doré s'apaiser au revoir